(box thumps)
(ambient music)
(plastic rustling)
(metallic jingling)
- I am a minimum wage worker.
(heartbeat thumping)
(intense music)
- I'm a millionaire.
We're about to look at
some bank statements.
(light switch clicks)
- Look at that.
- There's a Pokemon
collection.
- Pokemon collect 15,000.
- And the Pokemon collection
is 15K.
- Wait, hold. Onlyfans? Yo, yo, yo.
- No.
- Yo, bro.
I don't feel like you make
enough to be looking at girls.
(upbeat hip-hop music)
- My name is Brennan Jacobs,
and I am a minimum wage
worker who lives in LA.
- [Interviewer] What do you
predict people might say
after they see your finances today?
- I'm really scared that
they're gonna be like
if you know you don't have enough money,
why did you get this thing?
(light switch clicks)
(heartbeat thudding)
- Here, check this out, $31 at Taco Bell.
- Maybe he paid for him
and friends.
- What?
- We got another $18 for pizza.
Starbucks, $4.51 cents.
- I'm reading-
- Raising Canes is, 11 bucks there.
- Yogurt Land.
- A Yogurt Land, man. See it's like-
- He got an oil change.
In and Out,
- In and Out.
- Starbucks again.
- Again. See like Chick-fil-A,
Chick-fil-A, Chipotle.
- Yo.
- Another McDonald's, another Starbucks.
- [Christianna] $700 from Venmo.
So he might have a side hustle.
It's giving side hustle
- Could be parents.
- Oh yeah, I did have a lot of help at 19.
- He's getting-
- Wait, is this a...?
He spent 616 and only had $58.
Why would you spend this?
W/D from DDA.
- W/D from DDA.
- I have no clue what that is.
- Why would you take
your account that low?
Maybe he knew he had money coming in?
- And then we got a StubHub here.
- Wait, hold on. Onlyfans?
- No.
- Yo, yo, yo.
- Bro, I don't feel like
you make enough to be looking at girls.
- The we have this one
again at Sunset Boulevard.
W/D from DDA.
- Maybe this is the rent.
- ATM usage fee.
And then again at Starbucks.
- [Interviewer] He also
works at Starbucks?
- So why is he spending money there?
They don't give you free drinks?
- You would think.
- It's serious.
- It's giving like I have
a macchiato addiction.
- You can make that at home.
- You know how to make macchiatos?
- Yeah, it's actually...
you could go on YouTube.
We should go to Instagram.
- No, no, no,
if you're saying Willow,
you went to Coachella
Where'd you get Coachella money?
It's crazy how people will find money
for the things that they want,
but not for what they need.
Does that make sense?
Like-
- Most expensive items.
PlayStation 5, 570.
- I have one.
- You could resell that though.
They they keep about the same-
- Do you play video games?
- No.
- That's why.
I am an avid gamer.
You should get on Twitch
(speaker laughing)
And start making some money off of it.
You could be making extra money
with the time you spend on the game.
(tense orchestral music)
- Average monthly income, $1,300.
- Huh?
- That's not enough.
- First off, wherever you work,
- Yeah.
- Get another (censored) job bro.
Since you work at Starbucks,
why are you paying for it?
- Yo, okay, let me tell you.
(speaker laughing)
So I actually do get free food and drinks,
and I did not necessarily understand that
when I first got hired.
Genuinely, like, I don't
know what it looks like
to buy groceries.
So I just get fast food,
because my mom would be like,
"Oh, just go buy like
groceries for the week."
But I would be like, I don't have money
for groceries for a week.
- And I can understand that.
A lot of men like really don't know
how to properly grocery shop.
They buy three gallons of orange juice.
(tense rock music)
- My name is Isela Barra and
I'm a minimum wage worker.
- [Interviewer] What are
your financial goals?
- To be able to live off of my art,
like acting, dancing, performing.
(heart thumping)
- I like this, making money from Twitch.
$425 in a month.
- So she has consistent income.
- That's great.
- $135 on the phone.
That's normal.
- [Speaker] What do
you mean that's normal?
$135 for a phone bill?
- But she's by herself probably.
- I'm by myself, it's
$50 a month Boost Mobile.
Unlimited everything.
- You have Boost Mobile?
- Yeah, prepaid.
- Are you serious now?
- Yeah, seriously.
- All right, and then she
has her car payment, 276.
- [Speaker] Not bad.
- Normal.
Why are you making the minimum payment
on your credit card?
As long as that's keeping
it below 30%, that's okay.
And then Venmo,
so maybe she has income
coming in from Venmo.
- She paid five fifty for Venmo?
- [Christianna] Oh.
- [Speaker] So that's a withdraw.
- [Christianna] Oh,
because her rent is 550.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's her split.
Twitch.
So she makes money from Twitch.
- Yeah, that's consistent.
You could make a $1,000 a month.
- She could definitely bring that up.
- Yeah.
There's nothing bad in here.
- Oh, she does Insta work.
- Yeah.
- She does just like random gigs.
So she's a hustler at the end of the day.
- Yeah.
- She's a hustler.
- A Twitch at, let's see the at.
Yeah
- She's into clothes, like in fashion.
She's into cosplay and things like that.
- Yeah, it could be expanding to YouTube.
Then we get Car 2020 Kia Soul, 20 grand.
All right.
PC, oh she needs that for work.
Sewing machine, that's pretty cool.
- She makes clothes.
(tense orchestral music)
- Average monthly income, $1,500 a month.
- So one third of that
is straight from Twitch,
which is super dope.
- That's not bad.
- I feel like whatever you're
doing on Twitch, expand on it.
- Yeah, if you have an audience
enough to make $500 a month,
guaranteed you could make
three, four grand a month.
- Consistently too.
- That's pretty good.
Look at this average on food per month.
$10?
- She lives at home.
- How do you spend $10 a month on food?
What are you eating?
- Well, that was like for
going out like average.
I don't eat out that often,
but like I get food stamps right now so.
- Oh.
- That's where-
- That's how you're not spending food.
- I spend groceries, I
eat at home, but yeah.
- That's smart.
- How many hours a day are you working?
- I mean honestly I feel
like I'm always working
'cause I do do YouTube,
and so that's like editing.
I just don't have income from it yet.
But then I get part-time gigs
almost every day or every other day,
since I can make my own schedule.
Yeah, it's usually like
maybe five or eight hours.
- So you're constantly working.
She's on the right track.
You just need to take-
- That's why I have no life.
- Yeah
- You just need to take a
percentage of what you're making,
and start saving it.
(tense rock music)
- [Isela] All right.
- [Brennan] All right, perfect.
- [Interviewer] So which document
are you guys looking at right now?
- Document one.
- Yeah, document one.
- [Interviewer] Look at the next one.
If you add those two together,
that should be how much cash he has.
(money slot dings)
- [Isela] $3,280,129.
- [Brennan] $3,280,129.
and twenty nine cents.
- [Isela] Okay.
- [Brennan] So first, haircut
at Great Clips for $22.
- [Isela] $22.
- That's less than my
haircut, which is crazy.
Okay, wait, we need to
figure what fish means,
'cause we're looking
at one that says fish.
- There's so many aquatic treasures.
- Right.
- This must be like a hobby?
- Maybe something like that-
- And they collect exotic
animals like a shark.
Those are like-
(Brennan laughing)
- You think it's a shark?
- The baby shark thing, (indistinct)
- Oh, yeah.
- I'm just imagining when
you first walk into a house
and there's an aquarium in the
wall, you know what I mean?
- [Isela] Yeah.
- [Brennan] And it's
just like decked out with
(indistinct) fish.
- [Isela] That's probably what it is.
A lot of Amazon purchases.
- Yeah, what is that one?
(Isela laughing)
- Amazon.
- Okay.
- The saltwater fish was $346.
- [Isela] A Vegas show at the-
- [Brennan] Theater-
- [Isela] MGM theater.
$400.
- $400.
- They got a jet suite.
- So like a flight?
- Yeah.
- I think.
Ooh, yeah. Yeah.
And that was what?
$299.
- 299.
- Geico
- Geico Auto.
Cheap.
- It's 643.
- 643, dang.
I only play like 116, 117.
That's premium status, huh?
- Right, so the next
thing will be Instagram.
- Personal finance enthusiast
and real estate investor.
- 4 million on YouTube.
That's kind of cool.
- {Isela] We got top 10 assets.
Off the top of the list,
a 2005, Ford GT, $400,000.
Oh my god, there's the aquarium.
- Then the aquarium.
- 300 gallon reef aquarium, $55,000.
Is that just in total, or the whole thing?
- I think that is.
Wait, that's it. Okay.
- Is that Dory?
- So that's crazy.
Yeah, they got the whole cast in there.
(both laughing)
- The whole cast.
- [Brennan] Okay, so there's watches.
- [Isela] Watches.
- 20,000, $25,000, $50,000,
but the one that caught my eye
- [Isela] Look at that.
- [Brennan] There's a Pokemon collection.
- Pokemon Collect, 15,000.
- And the Pokemon collection is 15K.
That's crazy.
- Right?
- 'Cause they're all on
the wall and everything.
I would've never thought
a Pokemon collection
would've been $15,000.
(tense orchestral music)
- Average monthly income, $500,000.
- Freak. That's crazy.
Average towards savings
and investments per month
is 250,000 to 300,000.
How much do you put to
savings every month?
- Zero.
(Isela laughing)
- I agree on this. Zero as well.
- I don't extra really to be putting-
- Yeah.
- Into savings.
I guess I wanna know,
do you come from money?
How did you get to where you are?
- No, I don't come from money,
and a lot of that was from,
either real estate, or
making YouTube videos.
- Getting into real estate,
were your parents into that,
and so they kind of taught you?
- No, they thought I was crazy.
Both of them wanted me to go to college.
I didn't get into college, I
just had really bad grades,
and I decided I'd want to
get my real estate license
since I could do that online.
- Mm. Oh wow.
- That's cool.
(tense orchestral music)
- My name is Christianna
Hurt and I'm a millionaire.
- [Interviewer] What's your
opinion on like minimum wage?
- With minimum wage,
you're just in a different chapter.
Your today was my yesterday.
But we could both have the same tomorrow.
(switch clicks)
- The first thing I'm
noticing is designer clothing.
- Almost $1,600 for Rick Owens.
Very cool clothing, but
it is mad expensive, dawg.
Flowers.
- Flowers. $647.
- For flowers. What were the flowers for?
- [Isela] I wonder what... Yeah. Mm.
- I'm gonna make a guess and be like
she bought like Zendaya
flowers for her Emmy award.
- Zendaya, yes.
- Her Emmy award.
- Okay. We have-
- Ooh, I know that name.
Louis Vuitton.
- Okay.
- Okay, I see you.
- Yes.
- $3,834, a lot of plane tickets as well.
- Jet Blue Delta.
- Trip to Vietnam.
- Another trip.
- So $3,600.
A lot of very expensive
trips back to back.
Come with us to this Instagram link.
Public figure.
- Okay.
- @wealthycollegekid.
Okay.
So it looks like there's
classes that are being taught.
I'm not sure what it is,
but it's gotta be great.
We're getting money from it.
And then, let's click on
an Israel travel vlog.
So I feel like we definitely
are in the midst of traveler.
- A YouTube-
- And most expensive asset list.
- No, not again.
- Pokemon cards.
- What is this?
- 25,000?
There is something.
- Is there a thing millionaires
just collect Pokemon cards?
- We are seeing it.
- That's what we gotta do.
(tense orchestral music)
- Monthly income, 245,000 to 275,000.
Average monthly expenses is 5,000.
- [Isela] Insurance.
- [Brennan] Per month is 1,100.
- And she pays the insurance
for her entire family.
Well see...
- That's sweet.
Spent 40K on a trip to Dubai, 10K a night.
- Oh man.
- That's something I can never understand.
Or maybe I hope one day I
could, but right now I do not.
Do you just go on those trips
for fun or were they just...
- Or business?
- So somebody I know died,
so it kind of knocked me off.
So when I entered 2022
I decided literally at New Year's
we're gonna do 22 countries in 2022.
So we're at 13 countries,
I'll finish at 22 countries in December.
- I respect that a lot.
That's a really good answer.
I really like that.
(switch clicks)
- [Speaker] Hey, what's up?
- What's good, brother?
- Hi.
(people laughing)
- How's it going?
- Hi, hi.
- We're little-
- You too.
- I got you.
I feel like definitely
the difference between me
and both of you is the
planning out financially.
I feel like since I'm in a-
- [Isela] Live in the moment.
- Yeah, and honestly just I
live in paycheck to paycheck,
I feel like I'm like almost to a place
where I'm like how am I
ever gonna get out of that?
- Yeah, I just gotta save I guess.
- I truly wish I could make my
bank statement like one page.
- Oh no, no, no.
- You really used Boost Mobile.
- I told you.
- I was really hoping that was a lie.
- I told you, it's got a joke.
- $22 for the haircut.
- You didn't believe me, I'm like yeah.
- Wait hold on-
- Haircuts are cheap, $50.
- [Christianna] $236 for a fish?
- Yes, it's just one fish though.
It was multiple fish.
Wow, you spent $21,000 a
month on your credit card.
- I was focusing on my
mental health, honestly.